hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
norman bowie in his essay accounting
approach to business ethics applies the
second formulation of the categorical
imperative within business settings
showing us how
the treatment of workers and
particularly the example of layoffs
can be either in accordance with or
against our moral obligations to
those people and cons second formulation
of the categorical imperative
runs act always so as to treat humanity
whether in the person of yourself or
that of others
never as a mere means but always as an
end so it's rather complicated
formula but it can be reduced down to
treating people as ends in themselves
not merely as means and this has several
correlates that means that we shouldn't
reduce people down to say their market
value
we should
respect their human dignity even if we
think that they're not contributing that
much we shouldn't evaluate them solely
in terms of what are you know the value
added that they bring or anything like
that we have a duty to treat them as
genuine human beings and to respect
their autonomy and autonomy means a
capacity to decide for oneself among
other things
now as bowie is going to point out
this this injunction to not treat people
as mere means doesn't rule out any sort
of commercial transactions per se
it does place certain limits on the
structures of those he says no one is
used merely as a means in a voluntary
economic exchange where both parties
benefit why because it's not so much
just on the benefit part it's the
voluntary part if i can
will willingly choose to enter into a
contract or
to take on a client or to work with this
supplier or to purchase this product
that's respecting my autonomy if i'm
being coerced into it if i'm being
corralled into having only one option or
only one decent option then my autonomy
is not being respected
and
bowie is going to point out that it's
very important to acknowledge and
distinguish between negative and
positive freedom so
for kant negative freedom is going to
involve at the very least refraining
from deception or coercion
in how we treat other people and those
are very broad terms that include a lot
he quotes christine coarsegaard great
conscience scholar here who says
according to the formula of humanity
coercion and deception are the most
fundamental forms of wrongdoing to
others the roots of all evil they
violate the conditions of possible
ascent and all actions which depend on
their that for their nature and efficacy
on their coercive or deceptive character
are ones that others cannot ascend to so
if i am coercing you or if i'm depriving
you of information that you actually
need to make an informed choice i am not
treating you as an end i'm treating you
as a mere means to whatever
stockholder returns my own wish to
dominate pick whatever it is that you
like
positive freedom
involves permitting or perhaps even
fostering the development of human
capacities and this is very important
for kant not only our own capacities but
the capacities of others even if they
pass up the opportunity to do so we we
must act in such a way as to at least
allow them the chance to develop their
capacities so he's got a great example
here
layoffs of employees
he says
americans have been deeply concerned
about the massive layoffs created by the
downsizing of corporations in early and
mid-1990s it's still something going on
today
are these layoffs immoral and he says
that a naive conscient perspective would
say yes you just simply can't do those
those are wrong why because many of the
layoffs can be framed in terms of
employees being used as a mere means to
what
stockholder
returns
you you lay off employees so that the
company will be more profitable and then
you know perhaps the company's been
purchased uh by another company we can
think of all the different mergers that
have been going on
particularly in the tech sector
generally when your company gets
purchased um especially the further down
you are on the on the scale that's bad
news for you it's usually really bad
news for middle management as well
so
you know
why do they lay off the employees
because they're
in britain they talk about them being
made redundant right redundant means
you've got more than one thing
for the same function so get rid of all
the you know trim the fat as they say
get rid of all the dead wood is another
phrase if you're doing that you're
treating somebody as fat or as dead
would or as a cost you're not treating
them as a human being
now bowie says let's go a little bit
deeper that may be the case for some
some cases you know situations there are
ceos who have a reputation for just
coming in and gutting companies
they would be failing by by that measure
but
it could be that you could say well
listen when you become an employee you
know that there's the possibility of
layoffs
so
why are you complaining about that
you've entered into this work
relationship voluntarily here's where a
couple other considerations would come
up
so
employees could say
in a bad economy we have to take
whatever work we can get some people
have been out of work for six months a
year they have to take whatever
conditions are going to be offered to
them in order to be able to make money
and support themselves and perhaps their
families so in that case could we say
that some coercion is going on
many employees argue that in times of
high unemployment job insecurity
employees must accept job offers on
management terms
so you don't actually accept the threat
of a layoff to enhance shareholder
wealth freely you're not saying that
it's a fair system i'm going to enter
into it you're saying it's a rigged
system but i have to do it so that would
be a problem another is where you've got
a company that has a tradition of a
certain kind of
bargain
where employees are being given job
security
in exchange for what employee loyalty
being asked to do things extra being
asked to contribute to the corporate
culture being asked to
you know follow through on all the
things that otherwise you know
statistically might might fall through
the cracks it gives an example such as
ibm
at ibm there was such a long tradition
of job security in exchange for employee
loyalty so changing those rules amounted
in in bowie's view to both deception and
coercion on the part of management
um here we might talk about well what
would be required in order for
layoffs
to actually be
fair and justifiable under the second
formulation
the really key issue
is a problem with information asymmetry
which means that management knows what's
going on the employees don't know what's
going on and this applies not just to
business organizations this applies to
universities this applies to government
agencies there's quite often a vast
information asymmetry we can also say
that there's information asymmetry on
the part of the company in relation to
consumers or customers or clients as
well but that goes a little bit further
but it could it could apply to the same
sort of questions so
when there's high information asymmetry
one side is information it keeps from
the other side there is a severe
temptation for abusive power and
deception so a conscience bowie says
would look for ways to reduce the
information asymmetry between management
and employees are there such
possibilities indeed there are
so he talks about open book management
open book management
under it he says all employees are given
all the financial information about the
company on a regular frequent basis with
complete information in the proper
incentive employees behave responsibly
without the necessity of layers of
supervision and this would go a long way
towards correcting he says the
asymmetrical information that manager
managers possess a situation that
promotes abuse of power and deception so
this is a you could say a means to
institutionalize kant's second uh
formulation of the categorical
imperative not just in relation to
layoffs but in relation to all sorts of
other
problematic issues that could arise as
well so this is how
kant's second formulation at least in
terms of the negative freedom could
apply within the workplace